une première journée plutôt mitigé un
compliqué dans l'organisation compliqué
et dans la logistique
à titre d'exemple la mairie du 15e
arrondissement de paris s'est transformé
en centre de vaccination il ya donc
fallu faire appel à toute une équipe
médicale est installé et des
congélateurs pour pouvoir stocker est
les doses de vaccin faire connaissance
avec le logiciel mise à disposition par
l'état afin d'enregistrer les patients
vaccinés
et tout ça en un temps record vous
imaginez que ce n'est pas simple pour
une mairie de ce type
de nombreuses personnes se sont quand
même attroupés devant la mairie afin de
pouvoir simplement obtenir un
rendez-vous puisque les services
téléphoniques étaient saturées pour les
passions chant ce même là encore une
fois la prise en charge d un patient qui
ont pu se faire vacciner aujourd'hui a
été compliqué vous l'aurez compris ça
c'est un sentiment partagé entre un
soulagement pour les premiers servis et
un des pis pour ceux qui cherchent
encore à décrocher un rendez vous
écouter à mon dernier passage à la
mairie on m'a donné une feuille en
disant faites ce numéro de téléphone
commencé à appeler à huit ans et demi
on va vous contacte et on va fixer un
rendez vous bon je me suis levé de bonne
heure pour être à l'heure du j'ai
commencé à téléphoner à 20 heures du
matin jusqu'à 12h45 à chaque fois le
téléphone sonne et sony sony au bout de
quelques tombes disait c'est ont compris
ya trop de demandes
attendez un peu on vous rappelle
hombourg appel j'en ai marre j'ai laissé
tomber on m'a dit non non c'est on va
pas vous vacciner tout de suite on va
prendre vos coordonnées on vous tiendra
au courant vous téléphone tu parles moi
je ne crois pas à leur téléphone
ils vont changer de m'appeler peut-être
ils m'appelleront le jour mais les
héritiers vont lui dire ça y est les
morts de fugue octas parcours du
combattant
au tout début en arrivant à la mairie du
ivème pour me renseigner à quel endroit
on devait se faire vacciner
et là je reconnais qu'il ya eu une
période de flottement
le pub et que je mettrais sur le sur le
fait que c'était un début c'est le
premier jour et contrairement à beaucoup
de gens je je vais faire la déclaration
suivante je suis très optimiste pour 7,7
ce début de vaccination et je crois que
le message qu'il faut faire passer à
tout un chacun sait que il faut avoir un
peu patience mais tout le monde va
arriver à ce qu'il désire c'est à dire
sans sortir au plus vite de cette de
cette saloperie
du côté de la mairie du 15e
arrondissement on pointe du doigt encore
une fois un manque d'anticipation du
gouvernement et surtout en manque de
confiance envers elle et collectivités
locales depuis le début de l'épidémie
elle les mairies elles sont livrées à
elles-mêmes et on craint de prendre du
retard sur cette première campagne de
vaccination publique adressée aux
personnes à haut risque et aux personnes
âgées c'est en tout cas l'avis du maire
du xvème arrondissement philippe goujon
nous avons dû aménager les salles les
files actives
nous avons dû acheter des réfrigérateurs
nous avons dû demander rechercher les
médecins les infirmières mettre en place
tous les systèmes techniques
technologiques nécessaires
les services de sécurité enfin bref tout
était organisé par nous mêmes l'état
nous fournissant les doses mais nous
sommes un centre de vaccination à plein
régime
tout était prévu pour vacciner mille
personnes par jour et malheureusement
nous allons recevoir seulement 500 doses
par semaine ce qui nous permettra de
vacciner uniquement 80 personnes par
jour au lieu de 1000 je crois que c'est
le manque d'anticipation comme on l'a vu
pour les masques ou pour les dépistages
au début en tout cas mais aussi
peut-être plus structurellement un
manque de confiance de l'autorité
administrative par rapport aux
collectivités locales l'état trop
centralisateur trop bureaucratique
n'arrive pas finalement à être
suffisamment souple et réactif pour
organiser les
nécessité de la crise or nous petites
entités
nous sommes très réactifs très souple
d'emplois et donc près du terrain nous
pouvons mettre en place des choses
beaucoup plus rapidement pour cette
première journée de vaccination ce sont
près de 25 personnes qui ont reçu le
précieux sésame dans cette mairie bien
loin des 80 espérer et c'est le même son
de cloche à travers la france pour
rappel ce sont près de 6 millions de
personnes qui sont concernées par cette
campagne de vaccination public par cette
première étape en tout cas de campagne
de vaccination public
mais l'inquiétude demeure pour les
mairies et les collectivités locales
quant au délai imposé par le
gouvernement